ternheim schule darf ich jetzt begrüßen
meinen kollegen und chefreporter peter
tiede und peter du erinnerst dich auch
noch am letzten sonntag da haben wir
wirklich was erlebt du warst mit in
russland bist mit der maschine mit
alexei navalny nach russland geflogen
hast das alles begleitet wir hatten hier
eine sondersendung wie sehr berührende
ich jetzt diese bilder diese proteste
wir haben uns ja wir machen es gar kein
bild davon was es bedeutet in russland
auf die auf die straße zu gehen
das ist was anderes ob man hier gegen
die masken auf die auf die straßen geht
das ist in russland bedeutet dass
erstens lebensgefahr zweitens gerade für
junge leute die können sich damit das
gesamte leben verbrauchen also wenn da
auf die straße geht der riskiert
wirklich etwas alexander weiß der es
geht ja wirklich auch sein leben und die
jungen leute die für alex handy auf die
straße gehen die riskieren ihre zukunft
es gab im jahr 2012 einmal groß proteste
genehmigte groß proteste gingen gegen
wladimir putin und damals sind auch
studenten festgenommen und ich habe mal
längs interview gemacht mit einem mit
einem dieser studenten und was das
bedeutet der hat er neun monate später
ist er verhaftet worden ersten neun
monate nach nacht eigentlichen demo also
das kann jetzt immer noch jeden treffen
auch für heute nicht verhaftet worden
ist wie haben jetzt 1600 verhaftung dort
wir heute nicht verhaftet worden ist der
kann immer noch verhaftet wenn dieses
regime greift auf monate später dazu und
dieser junge mann damals einer
genehmigten demonstration erst
niedergeschlagen worden
von einem von einem polizisten essen zu
zweieinhalb jahren lagerhaft verurteilt
worden lagerhaft ist nicht der normale
haft gegen russland schon wirklich
grausam bis sondern lagerhaft ist
wirklich ein arbeitslager und das und
von daher berührt mich dass ich mich das
wirklich ich kenne einige aktivisten
auch leute die alexei navalny nahe
stehen die in russland sind ja heute
dort mit auf der mit auf der straße
waren und diese leute riskieren wirklich
viel da machen wir uns kommen ein bild
davon
es ist also diese bilder sind auch
wirklich völlig verstören das ist so was
jetzt überhaupt 2021 gibt kannst du uns
da vielleicht auch erklären wir wissen
ja in russland gibt es ganz andere
berichterstattung als hier
wie kommt es trotzdem dazu dass sich die
menschen gruppieren und jetzt
tatsächlich diese proteste und
demonstrationen stattfinden also der der
gemeinde große kümmert sich nicht mehr
um die politik die leute sind inzwischen
abgestimmte das gab anfang der 90er
jahre als sperren
oder ende der ende der 80er jahre und in
den 90er jahren also perestroika gehabt
michael gorbatschow da sind die leute
dann danach abgestumpft weil sie gemerkt
haben dass sie tatsächlich ausgeraubt
wenn zwar schon boris jelzin es war
schon ein unfassbar korruptes system
danach kam dann tatsächlich wie lange
putin hat erstmals sind dann dann hat
zugesichert dass das er straffrei
ausgeht und dann kam die silowiki das
ist das system das land putin aufgebaut
hat geheimdienstler die das land
ausrauben also der geheimnis hat den
start dort übernommen und das ist
wirklich gefährlich wenn man da auf die
straße geht und der gemeinde rose guckt
nach unten und da guckt herunter kümmert
sich nicht darum aber wenn ihm dann der
staat doch begegnet wenn ihnen doch die
korruption begegnet wenn er selber opfer
wird dann reißen sie sich auch schon mal
die brust bauch und dann steht und dann
stehen sie da und alexei navalny hat das
wirklich unglaublich geschickt gemacht
und das zeigt auch warum er so
gefährlich will den kreml ist warum
wladimir putin angst vor ihm hat er
zeigt er immer wieder korruption
aufwärts zeigt immer wieder diesen
unfassbaren reichtum auf den sich diese
mafia clique und lade mir putin
angeeignet hat er hat einmal ein
wirklich berühmtes video gemacht über
den reichtum von von mit weniger von dem
premierminister dadurch für den luxus
palast gezeigt und viel an und und viele
andere sachen und jetzt hat er direkt
nach seiner einreise nach russland hat
sein team ein anderthalbstündiges video
veröffentlicht in dem er unter anderem
zeigt einen großen palast von wladimir
putin ein unfassbar große style am
schwarzen meer voller gold von
unfassbaren reichte mir das ist der
grösste palast denen das glaube ich
weltweit gibt momentan die sich
irgendjemand hingezaubert hat also
selbst in der arabischen welt wurden
würden die scheichs erblassen vor neid
ein 1,5 milliarden euro teures teuren
palast und das macht alexander weiß und
das bringt dann auch gerade die jungen
leute auf dem plan wenn man das gesehen
hat wo in russland überall heute
demonstriert worden ist es ist er am
frühen morgen große hat elf zeitzonen
und wenn wir uns mal die karte angucken
können die es da gibt also fangen wir
mal rechts im bild an bei wladiwostok
und chabarowsk das ist unten wirklich
ganz unten das ist kurz vor japan
das ist bei nordkorea und da hat es am
morgen angefangen und denken und dann
ging es weiter über auch über toms von
wo aus alexander weiden damals damals
damals losgeflogen und am späteren
nachmittag jetzt unsere einfach
zeit sind die demonstration in moskau
und in st petersburg man sieht wirklich
das geht durch durch das gesamte land
man darf sich jetzt wie täuschen dass
wir alles nur im süden des wir haben
hinten haben wir haben wir sieben da ist
im norden quasi nicht da sind die
großstädte sind immer im süden sind eher
südlich und da es ist wirklich
massenphänomen in den großstädten man
darf sich auch nichts vormachen weil auf
dem land gehen nicht auf die straße da
ist dass er gibt die ländliche
bevölkerung ist davon weitgehend
abgeschnitten
und wir dürfen aber nicht vergessen 95
prozent der russischen medien sind nicht
mehr in freier hand und ein der größte
medienkonzern in russland zum beispiel
ist gazprom gazprom media eine tochter
von der staatlichen gas sowie bei uns
jetzt gerade ihre blutige pipeline
weiterbauen darf das ist eine der
größten propaganda steuern die sie
überhaupt nicht und darauf baut wladimir
putin und alexei navalny unterläuft
dieses system immer sehr sehr geschickt
mit seinen youtube videos ja und die
demonstranten die riskieren wirklich
alles so hat es gerade erklärt und auch
wir haben es auch schon gesagt bei bis
zu minus 30 grad das finde ich auch
wahnsinn also den leuten liegt wirklich
was daran sie geben alles jetzt gehen
auf die straße wie gefährlich könnten
diese demonstrationen denn für putin
überhaupt werden oder kann ihnen das
nichts also es scheint ihm gefährlich zu
sein weil sonst würde er die staatsmacht
nicht mit dieser brutalen gewalt
rausschicken das system putin beruht
darauf dass ist ein aufstiegsversprechen
an die mittelschicht gibt dass jeder
robuste merkt es wird ein bisschen
besser das aufstiegsversprechen kann er
lange nicht mehr halten also erstmal
jetzt können sie wegen irgendwie nicht
wirklich aber unter wladimir putin hat
sich der rubel der werte sowohl halbiert
moskau waren die 90er jahren einmal die
teuerste stadt der welt davon ist man
weit entfernt man ist jetzt zwischen auf
berlin auf berliner niveau wenn man der
essen geht und wenn man es theater geht
und solche sachen
das funktioniert nicht mehr die leute
werden kommen nicht mehr zum wohlstand
sie können bestimmte sachen nicht mehr
reisen es gibt sanktionen es gibt auch
sanktionen die russland selber russland
selber fängt hat die den lebensstandard
der russen einschränken
und dann kommt allerdings länderwahl nie
und bei dem funktioniert es nicht also
selbst der tod funktioniert bei ihnen
nicht also man hat versucht ihn
umzubringen man hat ihnen immer wieder
inhaftiert und hat alles mögliche
gemacht und immer wieder man kriegt
diesen keim nicht erstickt und das ist
das was man glaube ich zur weißglut rad
und was da auch wirklich hat schon köpfe
rollen lassen in dem system
weil man wenn man nachweisen die nicht
auch nicht aus der welt kriegt und wenn
dani weitermacht und neuwahlen jetzt
inzwischen geschafft von einem
einzelkämpfer die man immer unterstellt
hat er sei eigentlich ein nationalist
sich wirklich zum demokraten hin hin zu
entwickeln und er hat in allen
großstädten die wir gerade auf der karte
gesehen haben da hat er jetzt inzwischen
niederlassungen da hat er eigene büros
da hat der unterstützer komitees die für
ihn wie arbeiten und vor ort unterstützt
er dann immer die opposition geht ist
ihm dann auch relativ wo ist wären die
opposition kann das können auch mal die
kommunisten seien aber einfach immer
gegen die putin partei die alles
beherrscht die das land wirklich
unterjocht hat und das land aussaugt und
da unterstützer die und das kann eine
gefahr seien
es ist nicht die gefahr dass ein dass
ein umsturz droht aber wirklich dass
wladimir putin von seinem hohen sockel
und runter kommt und dass die russen
merken es gibt eine andere welt und das
was uns erzählt wird was uns in den
nachrichten erzählt wird das stimmt
nicht ich kenne selber moskauer die
höheren kein auto radio hören einfach
keinen keinen rat über die sagen wenn
man drei stunden durch dann weil drei
stunden durch durch die stadt fahren und
du wirst mit der propaganda berieselt
die da in den sendern kommt wenn du am
anderen ende roskosmos bleibt immer
etwas hängen ganz kurz jetzt noch
zusammengefasst wie wird es mit einer
weile weitergehen also wir haben ja
letzten sonntag die bilder gesehen ihr
wart ganz nah dran als er dann
mitgenommen wurde er kam in ein
gefängnis erst mal dass auch dafür
bekannt ist ja gefährlich zu sein ist ja
da noch wie geht's weiter ganz kurz das
gefängnis heißt matrosen ruhe ist ganz
beruhigt ich da ist ja noch und aus
diesem gefängnis kommt man auch nicht so
schnell raus sagt tauchen leute oftmals
nicht mehr auf oder kommen direkt in den
gulag ersten 30 tägige haftstrafe
und danach wird er die nächste wird er
wohl die nächste haftstrafe kriegen es
gibt genügend verfahren die ihm da
angehängt werden er wird von der weide
jetzt nicht rauskommen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schaut
euch hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren